our favorite Nintendo consoles figured
this be a good one to bring you on
because you had a different take on you
were going to talk about the Nintendo
3ds we can get into that portable yeah
so Nintendo platform might be the more
accurate description for this segment we
have giveaways and self later to get
back into but yeah I'll start with you
Mary cuz like I said you're not always
on camera this last time so hit me with
your favorite Nintendo platform I kind
of just prefaced it right yeah it would
have to be the 3ds which has just been
so monumental to my life these last few
years it's like my go-to a put it in a
bag and I take it with me it's just done
such a great job at having really
quality games and you guys already
talked about all the really good Zelda's
which are on the 3ds right but including
like a link between worlds which was
gamespot's game of the year 2013 sore
talking really high quality games some
in which you can only get on the 3ds and
then in addition to that I would say
it's the most social portable handheld
that you can find right now from games
like Super Smash Bros to Mario Kart lets
you play with a pool of friends even if
they don't own the game and I think
that's really cool and innovative and I
think every every console should follow
that right I think if your friend has it
you should be able to play with them and
enjoy that game at that time a better
example in streetpass yeah holy [ __ ]
that is such that was such a smart move
by Nintendo it's really fun and I don't
know if we utilize it as much as like
Japan does like it is incredible if you
go overseas and then you like check your
3ds and you get check-ins from people
all over the world all over the world
who love their 3d yes and they give you
a little message and they have little
hats and they live in your 3ds and there
I really open it up I've contained a lot
of humans in there these are people that
I was near at one point in my life I
like that this little this little
reminder that there are other people
that like the same thing that you do and
to the point where you know with a lot
of Pokemon games and other games no you
can like fight with them on the street
right you can like challenge kids and
stuff to fist fights that's right
especially if you lose
I remember like being at a party like a
kind like one of those like lame parent
party is right but one of them had a kid
a young kid who was like super shy
wouldn't talk to anyone had a 3ds we
played 3ds games like it was a very
social interaction that I enjoy it was a
way for me to connect with another dude
that I would never been able to connect
with and then on top of that they did a
really good connection with the wii with
the wii u i was able to play monster
hunter 3 and connect on to the wii u and
play online with another person awesome
so I'm playing Monster Hunter 3 and then
I maybe have to go somewhere a hop on a
bus and I can continue leveling up my
character I'd never seen that before I
know you could do that and that's such a
precursor to what it's doing now right
which is play at home and then take it
with you and keep playing so 3ds is very
near and dear to my heart it's funny
like somebody just asked me other day
like what's the best hand hold in your
opinion and um sky hbu that treaty s
like it's just the most social friendly
handhold there is that lets you play the
game so the people and talk about games
with other people I love the 3ds
primarily for its library I think it's
amount the amount of awesome games on
there that you can't play on any other
platform is unreal you got to include
the d/s library with that too yeah
edible and like not to mention like you
said all like older Zelda games all
their like Metroid games are on there
yeah well in general it's I don't know
it's one of my favorite handhelds to it
is my favorite handheld that I've ever
had but I'm just playing like Majora's
Mask 3d Ocarina of Time 3d lately
between the those re-releases between
the you know the digital library it's
pretty unreal yeah it's so broad to like
you really hardcore games like bravely
default that take hours and hours and
hours to play or maybe you're just like
more into a platformer then you should
place shovel knight which is like such a
rad indie game like you're talking about
a huge spectre of games for all sorts of
different people it's just just
comfortable as hell especially the XL I
mean the original image I cut into your
palms a little bit but I I can play for
a long time on the three Axl now with
the rounded corners everything it's just
the size is perfect you can bring it
anywhere but it's also big enough to not
feel like you're squinting 3s great what
is your favorite console Pete do you
really look do you want to know yeah I
wanna do I want to know or do i do you
really want to know
really want to know Peter Brown it's
this stupid intend to other super by
surprise yeah this is knock if it's not
collecting dust bump your ground I don't
care it's a super famicom to be specific
ah what is that this japanese ullin ah
no uh okay to talk about excellent
library of games like Super Nintendo
yeah super Nintendo's got it any been to
Japan you can go to Japan yeah it's not
a company I thought it was just like a
thing people made up anyway shut up um
excellent library right a lot of things
people say about 3d su people you could
also say by the Super Nintendo but one
of things i really love just growing up
as a kid was that the super nintendo
seemed to just nail like the logical
conclusion of like 2d pixelated games at
the time everything the nes wanted to be
the super nintendo was and then some and
an even branched out introduced 3d
gaming in certain ways as well like Star
Fox for example totally unprecedented
for a console game so there are a lot of
reasons why that system will always be
near and dear to my heart but you know
the games that I love about it the ones
that i play on Virtual Console like
those are originated on Super Nintendo
and so its legacy is still felt today so
I'll always remember it is my favorite
what's a game you still go back to Super
Metroid it sound easy yeah finally fancy
six great attitude like that right about
three in America yeah yeah yeah um and
chrono trigger your fan oh my god Crone
triggers that is that is one but he's
gonna cry oh no it's that that game it
it was just a perfect storm of creative
visions and people working on it like if
you guys played chrono trigger before
yeah like I don't know like me did you
find like once you start playing it it's
just really hard to stop playing like
from the beginning of the game not like
a random session but when I whenever I
start playing chrono trigger the
soundtrack the series of events like it
feels great all over again every time
yeah the storytelling in general is
unreal yeah Becky you can finish it how
many different ways music
I like to listen the music on like road
trips and stuff like that's got a
fantastic soundtrack listening to it
right now what's the characters and
Jenna thing it for me if you like a
character I sing it characters are
really good um except that robot damn
robot uh what's his name chibi robo robo
uh the fraud yeah i was gonna we had
kind of brought it up earlier but mine's
the n64 it's what I grew up on kind of
came of age so to speak ocarina I
remember we got the ocarina of time like
day one and ninety eight rue des been 98
between that Majora's Mask playing
goldeneye playing perfect dark the rare
shooters before they started working on
like when they were working like banjo
kazooie into e after that but yeah i
don't know i still remember playing
ocarina i have like i have four older
siblings and they were always the ones
buying the games i just play whatever
they got yeah ocarina was the one that
number i would always get to like the
water temple my brother would have to do
it for me just because I don't know I
forgot how old I was in 98 I would have
been really young but too stupid to to
the watertown don't want to see was to
do a water temple but I remember that
was like it was weird that really was
one side beat Ocarina I felt like I
could beat anything but yeah there's
goob fact Mike became a man thanks the
n64 I don't know what you think I did to
that console but I importa yeah neo jet
age haha what did he had 64 hard drives
per diem for okay the perfect perfect
daughters amazing court in Tunisia angel
I completely agree not perfect dark zero
on 360 that game is [ __ ] perfect
dark in general in 64 is fantastic I the
n64 i still play you were playing road
rash yeah that's a game that Oh engines
the back when it was koo na dude it came
i speeded it was the thing to plan and
Sookie for with the license soundtrack I
believe on road rash know it had its own
thing beresch at one point and like the
most modern version of those games had a
license ound track yeah the xbox one
version there's no expert reason I know
yeah and Sakura is by far my favorite
might be my
console ever and that's I mean I love
Super Nintendo I didn't really grow up
on the Super Nintendo I we had one when
I was younger and even before that when
I was even younger we had an NES but I
never really played those as much
because I wasn't old enough to do those
things in my own just a wee tot tiny
little sparkle in my father's eye he was
the same proportion just this big yeah
people put me in their pockets I had to
link i had to jump from button to button
on the controller I sucked at mario i
never got past that first jump was about
they're probably ones that people wish
that we had said that we didn't bring up
that yeah um so in terms of launch
lineups I think the GameCubes wasn't it
really good was a super mario sunshine
is that it it's really good lunch line
up Luigi's Mansion I lose mansion I
forget man it's the first time i played
a game Pete was in a McDonald's remember
they had those kiosks set up did i do
not your mcdonalds have people know what
I'm talking about if you're in the chat
and you remember playing gamecube at
mcdonalds validate Mike yes please prove
to them i'm not crazy uh no I played I
played like Luigi's Mansion super smash
bros melee was unreal on that winwaker
res evil for metroid dan thank you had a
really good library a gamecube to me was
like the place the cool friend had like
that's where you went and that he had a
gamecube and everyone went over to their
house like into the basement didn't
carry it using the handle on the back of
the system over two years hey guys just
run down the street okay you remember
handle it was just a cube no it wasn't
it was your in singing it's got its got
a handle in the back I never used to hey
did it had a handle it was like one big
plastic brass knuckle yeah
eat it eat it get some chicky nibblers
and then go play some Luigi's Mansion um
where's the safe no right infringement
yeah I can't say the wood they really
are I don't think I used to have I used
to get a big mac and then just [ __ ]
slay in super smash bros melee I used to
like people used to come up and put
instead of putting corridors on the
console you just put a little chicken
nugget and then I'd have to eat it and
then we'd play and I win every time I'd
never had to pay for chicken nugget my
whole life because I was really good
with Mars and super smash bros melee and
they say and they say games can't pay
the bills he was like the bully of
mcdonalds that ruled the yas Mikey
McDonald thank you they called him I
push open the door and uh like a buzz
weed floats by is abuzz weed you guys
know I'm talking about when there's
drugs you never know what you're talking
about anymore I never do either um so
that's the game pube about game boy game
boy color not the same thing but came by
color link's awakening gameboy advance
do you also forgot about oracle of
seasons Oracle vision or five seasons
oracle of ages was Catherine aids all
the games yeah and they were good links
awakening was Game Boy originally I get
link's awakening DX added the color
dungeon on gameboy color that's a really
weird zelda but it's really good
tumbleweed thank you would you call them
buzz weeds thinking BuzzFeed market for
twenty busby there's tomorrow all right
uh anyway uh you kids want some buzz
weed dude buzz weeds legal here now like
a year tell me about it interesting all
that Busby I'm just trying to play some
gamecube games Jesus uh what other
councils were missing I don't know the
wii u wii u wii was good you guys say no
revolution oh boy their favorite but he
is acknowledged is one of the greatest
you know revolutions I mean it just
completely took the world by storm and
everybody's mom had a week and they all
did all their exercising on it it was
huge it was a phenomenon
I remember my parents hadn't played a
game in years we're playing wii bowling
and thought it was the best and to me
that was worth it like that was cool
does your dad like [ __ ] that was a
strike and you know it standing either
you know I upu you were like this not
[ __ ] it's like this shitty person
but it was a fun family game and people
liked playing it together and it did
that really well and you have to
acknowledge that it was I was really
cool minecraft I was the new Peter dude
we bowling do you guys know norm Duke is
he's that famous bowler who could do the
things through the chairs and with the
towel and then off people's heads won't
know anyone who has a towel would you
look at the time it's like saying you
know you're a football fan don't know
who like Jerry Rice's norm Duke dude the
Duke no one said we were bowling fans so
just talked about boy I didn't bring it
up you did all right anyway I don't
think virtual boy what about that bags
about bowling first boy had like an
imperial probe droid I had a great you
want talk about virtual boys I played or
playing games in weird environments I
saw the virtual boy first a blockbuster
hit kiosks there like a monthly or there
was something thin because no one wanted
a ferret Burger King 36 that's a lie ah
a great shooter from hudson soft i know
you guys all love hudson soft properties
was named one Bomberman oh [ __ ] he was
ready I just making stuff up now um
Mario clash was an interesting game
there was a like that Wario had a
platformer oh there oh they had a boxing
game on there that was basically punch
out in 3d it was great tell a row boxer
yeah and you guys don't even know no
speaking boxing game come to my house I
have what he can play it speaking of
boxing day to McDonald there's a there's
a bar in San Francisco called soda
popinski zan if you beat Mike Tyson and
punch out you get a bottle of champagne
they just continue that I thought oh
this'll do it probably because of Dan
Reicher didn't he do it yeah yeah I'm
you could differ another giant bomb yeah
yeah uh anything else trying to touch on
favorite consoles nothing did you uh
yeah we talked about a while I think
about the switch what do you think the
switch no no people talk about we you
honestly
hema well great library crap hardware no
said great library few good big library
no I think that was their problem yeah
alright we're about the NES the original
one go back to it what about it tell me
about it well you have like you have
like six collector's editions on on open
oh god shut up in a i was going to same
year as the NES and I had an older
brother and he bought all the games and
I loved it and it was my introduction
into video games a lot of our
introduction to video games was probably
is right like that was the one where you
saw somebody else play something well at
least most people at this table I was
too young but that was like where you
saw people play cool things and said I
want to play cool things too I've known
for loving metal gear and I the first
one in NES was like my first experience
with this series I could never get past
the second screen in that freaking game
but I played it all the tube on random
wall I'm so cool trial and error for me
it was getting around the dogs oh I
played for like two minutes and then
realize it was a bad idea not that bad
idea yeah about the new mini too little
guy classic mmm it's cool the controller
cables are too short I saw that people
around the world have mentioned such
short cables yeah everyone is selling
extension cables for tables it's like
but Nintendo's not having a problem
selling this thing so that doesn't
really matter hmm the game suction could
be better but you said splitting hairs
you said there was like trademarks or
copyright patents filed for super
nintendo classic nintendo did something
to recertify its design of the super
nintendo controller so i might stand a
reason that will see them make something
with that controller be it something for
switch for virtual console or a Super
Nintendo classic which I think would be
in their best interest to all right well
that was our discussion about not just
our favorite intento console but every
Nintendo console if you're watching in
the twitch youtube or gamespot chats let
us know you have been it's been great
and if you're watching this on youtube
or gamespot afterwards let us know in
comments below thanks so much
you
[Music]